we have a voicemail number it's two one
nine two david p i don't know if this is
the first voicemail exclusively focused
on pat maybe it is think so okay let's
take a listen man pat has been on fire
lately every video i see he's out there
making good points and he's really
become more confident since he first
started the show keep up the good work
alright Pat we have a positive voicemail
now and I'm sure you have to be prepared
that there will be now in response
negative Pat voicemails but that's okay
I am prepared I mean there are growing
pains and I think I'm getting through
them alright on the bonus show today we
will hear about Pat's jury duty
yesterday Pat was out yesterday because
of jury duty also former a producer
Lewis is calling in from I believe is in
Florida although he may have moved into
into Georgia now he's on an exploratory
mission to the southeast of the United
States we're going to be talking to him
extensively big-league on today's bonus
show so if you're not a member sign up
at david pakman.com slash membership you
can use coupon code i've oted 17 to get
a discount and please please please
please please donate at david pakman.com
slash donate we have a major indiegogo
crowdfunding campaign and i would love
for you to be a part of it